en este vídeo vamos a tomar nuestro
conector de 9 bolsas que usamos para
tomar la energía de la batería y que va
a nuestro robot y le vamos a cambiar los
cables trenzados de calibre 22 a cables
de núcleo sólido de cobre de calibre 18
que soporta mayor corriente sabemos que
nuestros motores pueden requerir de una
amperes cada uno así que queremos
asegurarnos de que los cables tienen la
capacidad de manejar esta corriente
hablaremos de esto en otro vídeo lo
primero que vamos a hacer es quitar la
cubierta plástica exterior que protege a
nuestro colector que me parece está
hecho de vinilo quizás de pvc vamos a
quitarla para exponer los cables y los
conectores vemos que atrás hay dos
remaches que están conectados a los
cables así que vamos a arrancar los
cables de los remaches jalando los de
manera que quitemos los cables y sólo
queden los remaches y los conectores al
cablear esto es importante que
coloquemos los cables en el lugar
correcto
la terminal positivo
es la que tiene arriba el punto en forma
de hongo y la terminal negativa va a ser
la más pequeña de las dos aqui soldamos
nuestro cable rojo en la parte de atrás
del conector para sostenerlo en su lugar
es importante tener un buen flujo de
soldadura alrededor de estas conexiones
hacemos lo mismo para la terminal
negativa
ya que tenemos conectados ambos cables
vamos a proteger la parte de atrás
usando un pedazo de envoltura que se
encoge la colocamos y hacemos dos
agujeros en ella para que salgan
nuestras conexiones así que despejamos
nuestros conectores del plástico
haciéndolo a un lado hacemos lo mismo
del otro lado y cortamos el exceso con
nuestro cutter
tomamos nuestra pistola de aire caliente
para encoger este plástico aplastamos la
parte que queda suelta mientras el
plástico siga suave ahora vamos a poner
nuestro nuevo conector en nuestras
baterías y nos ayudamos con nuestro
destornillador grande para empujar y que
encaje en nuestros conectores
y ahora que tenemos los cables en su
lugar es importante que no se toquen
entre sí ya que si se tocan harán
cortocircuito los cables se van a
calentar van a vaciar las baterías y nos
causarán problemas como no queremos que
esto suceda pasamos el cable negro por
abajo y a través del agujero que hicimos
para los cables de la batería
el cable rojo también pasará por este
agujero pero va a regresar por el
agujero que está junto al motor y una
vez que hagamos esto vamos a conectarlo
a nuestro interruptor para encender o
apagar nuestro robot
veremos cómo cablear el interruptor en
el siguiente vídeo